thank you guys we're here with an early
winner of today's round even shot each
one i had to prepare against you once
for one of my students and i thought man
this is a player that likes to take the
bull by the horns and today that made
out very well uh yeah he allowed me to
to play my game so to say and instead of
some solid lines like what he used to
play like petrov or
or berlin or french he chose this
neither variation and to be honest h6
was the move which i don't
recall so much
i mean nowadays they don't play it to be
honest during the game i
i had no idea
why or what to do but because white has
in general like uh castling is normal
but then afterwards like you can play h4
you can play king b1
also white can mix up some plans so
it's a bit tricky but it's like an old
line we see some of the
games in the database from gotti yeah
good old stuff gary i'm still running
around with this caspar chess foundation
here teaching some of the ukrainian
talented kids tell me exactly where he
went wrong where you felt that it was
over okay the main idea of h6 is to stop
g5 and to secure this knight on f6 which
secures the d5 square but the problem
black has
almost he can never castle after this h6
because after h4 he's just getting
checkmated so he's trying to play on the
queen side with quick b5 b4 ideas or
knight b6 knight c4 or knight a4s in the
game uh but during the game i felt like
maybe queen c7 was not necessary i'm not
sure increases having another way
okay yeah the engine seems to hate the
move questions i thought
knight b6 he will go anyway and i didn't
i thought that i would just leave this
pawn on d5 hanging and play
g5 anyway or even f4 is interesting
because if
black takes on d5 then what what knight
knight to db6 of course and now i don't
know either like f4 or g5 i was
considering g5 right yeah because if
knight d5 i can go bishop b4 and have a
domination on the light squares
after he probably has to take on e3
queen e3 and then i have strong square
on d5 and again he can't castle
maybe if he after g5 plays h5 and then
somehow manages to consolidate but
i thought this was
you came up with an interesting piece
sacrifice here you took on c4 now okay
when i see
class 4 here i have like during the game
it was all all very unclear to me but
[Laughter]
so it wasn't clear to you at this moment
when did you feel no this i liked very
much because i had this
feeling that the open files
you
favor white here and i thought white has
more than just one way to win this game
uh
yeah i had some small decision
whether to take with the c pawn or with
a pawn but i think it's better with a
because sometimes i take on this if he
takes with the queen i have bishop f4
winning the exchange and
then he has queen g6 check if i take
with the c pawn so you wanted to close
this diagonal g6
crusher victory to start the day here
how's it feel yeah finally a victory
i didn't have much chances only in the
second round i was completely winning
against mamijaro but
it feels like i've the games i've lost
which i lost i should not
i could have drawn drawn them and uh
but in general i think uh i'm satisfied
how i played the openings and the middle
games
but in the end games when i was long
time i was doing some
very bad decisions in first two days
well no need for an end game here he did
not survive even the opening yvonne
congratulations on your win guys let's
go back to the studio we still have four
games left absolutely uh congratulations
yvonne i was going to say very very
convincing